en 17 mois la première a eu le temps de
réfléchir à quelques améliorations de sa
piste de danse mais la plus grande
nouveauté pour cette boîte de nuit reste
la mise en place du pass en tête si vous
avez votre schéma vaccinal complet il y
aura aucun problème évidemment pour
entrer et puis si vous n'avez pas de
deux tests valide vous avez la
possibilité devant la première de vous
faire tester avec un test antigénique en
juillet marque vernis avait refusé de
rouvrir la première lors de la mise en
place du pass haltères pour les
discothèques mais aujourd'hui il change
d'avis on avait un vrai flou autour de
autour de ce pass sanitaire de
l'application de la compréhension aussi
voilà maintenant on a quelque chose qui
est un petit peu plus lisible pour les
utilisateurs après 17 mois sans voir un
seul client s'est ré ouverture est une
bonne nouvelle marc vernier préfère
toutefois ne pas s'enflammer on a quand
même une jauge qui est réduite on est et
on va être confronté quand même un
certain à certains problèmes justement
sur les validations des passes sur la
jauge dont non on espère en tout cas que
les beaux jours reviennent ça mettra à
mon avis un certain moment aussi à
revenir à la normale et à la normale si
bien aimé l'activité qu'au niveau du
financier grâce aux aides de l'état la
première a pu garder la tête hors de
l'eau mais à la fin du mois d'août ces
aides seront peut être supprimé pour
marc vernier il ne reste plus qu'à
espérer que les clients seront tous
rendez vous malgré le passé ni terre